and at the age of 25 i decided that
i want to break into the u.s market on
my own
[Music]
all right gil bernardi thank you for
joining 20 minute leaders
absolutely thank you so much for having
me you already told me you're going to
cheat on the last question so i'm so
excited for this interview because it's
going to be
i think different from all the rest gil
we know each other for for
uh many many years now and ever since i
think i came to visit you in palo alto
like six years ago uh for any meal
and the dietary the diet startup and
gil give me you know two three sentences
about up west and and what do you guys
do
i had an episode with julie but i but we
have it's it's
so amazing we have to talk about it
again there you go so you can compare
notes and see
if we're doing a good job there you go
so upwest is an early stage seed fund
we actually invest in both pre-seed and
seed stage
and we are tailor-made for israeli
founders
that are looking to break into the
earth's market so we are focused on
investing in israeli founders and
helping them in the early stages
of ramping up the team getting momentum
fundraising and so forth here in the us
uh we've done it for close to nine years
now we've backed over 80 companies that
raised over
yeah well over one billion dollars in
follow-on financing
uh first investor in sentiment one which
is a unicorn startup and many other
prominent companies
that uh we think at least a few will
reach that stage so
we've been super excited to do this for
a while now and
uh yeah i'm looking for the future ahead
amazing so i always joked with
with with the new funds that you know
when you start out
the lifetime of a company is like what
seven to nine years that's the
game you're going into so usually the
first few years you can kind of go along
without showing too many returns
because it takes seven to nine years but
you're you're there so now you have to
show returns and obviously
you've shown some pretty amazing returns
uh or you've shown amazing companies and
where they're where they're at now
and what is this idea of israelis in
silicon valley and disintegration and
adaptation yeah
so first of all uh night eight nine
years in vc
is very very young
i'm still learning every day it's the
equivalent of maybe eight nine months in
the startup so
we've been around for a while but you
know it takes how you feel really
decades um you know i think israel
always had a
very special relationship with the us
but on the tech fund specifically with
the valley
you've seen over the years fantastic
companies emerge here
um and in the last couple of decades in
particular
uh many fantastic companies uh such as
houzz and others
have emerged here by uh really
incredible israeli founders and our goal
is to level the playing fields for
israeli companies
that want to come here and get the same
opportunities that other
founders that are already based here
amazing how many how many companies
how many decks do you read a year
we see well over a thousand um
we invest in uh
far less than one percent um and
what the way we think about it is not
about screening them and stuff i mean
we spend a lot of time in israel and
here and whether it's zoom or in person
our goal is really also to give feedback
right we want to contribute to their
journey
uh give them some insights about the
market maybe a few competitors that
maybe have not
heard about or know you know or we can
add
more information about so we really want
to help them and advise them because
um you know they they they deserve it
incredible i don't know many people who
can talk about their job and say that
after nine years
of being in the same quote-unquote job
they're still
they're still learning every day and it
feels like they were only there for
eight or nine months so already
i'm inspired by this passion gil where
do you come from
you have a pretty interesting leeway
yeah
so uh israelis talking right um
um my first nine years i i was actually
born in belgium
um when my parents were in the very
early twenties and going to university
so
i was born in belsheva but i grew up my
first nine years in forsaba
we then moved to london i spent seven
years growing up in london my
i can feel it in the accent the accent
and definitely my passion for
specific music and sports uh emerged
there
what is that passion what is that music
ah
well growing up in london in the 80s
right
you can't attach to certain types of
music and you take it with you
but uh yeah it's uh i'm definitely
um like discovering you
new music on an ongoing basis i think
that's the way it began
uh came back to israel 16 back to
fosable
did my military service um wasn't
smart enough to be in 8200 and so forth
i'm the oldest of three siblings so i'm
the alpha version
the alpha person is like so my brothers
and sisters
my brother and sister did much better
than me of course but i i i spent uh
three years in in the armored corpse
did my undergrad and at the age of 25 i
decided that i want to um
break into the u.s market on my own
right uh no no real tech background
uh but i did want to know that i want to
spend some time here
and moved uh here to the maybe at
wharton
uh worked for bcg new york and then
yahoo and here we are
amazing what did you do at yahoo i
started
off in the corporate development team
and which was
amazing exposure go to work got to work
with fantastic people and even the
founders of yahoo
being israeli i sent myself to israel
once
or twice a year to see startups help
them
um but also ended up um acquiring
yahoo's first company in israel helping
to open the first rnd center in haifa
um and it's actually where the seeding
of sort of upwest began when i met
shooting 2006
and we start seeing stark differences
between
some of the founders here and some of
the founders in israel that was
that were at least on the same level in
terms of their
dna but maybe didn't have the same
opportunities that those that were
already based in the us
incredible i mean i was just such a
small kid you're talking you're saying
yahoo
that was about 2005 2006. uh starting
off five spent four years in copenhagen
operations yes
at that time i had my yahoo mailbox and
all my friends had a yahoo mailbox was
obviously a different time back then in
terms of the market share of the
companies
but that's incredible and gil you have
the unique
um experience of being a partner
in quite a few portfolio companies how
many portfolio companies do you see
through now
over the not over the past nine years
how many have we have
we've invested or seen right yeah i
invested in that europe invested in
82 82. okay so you have the unique
privilege
and the challenging role uh to come into
this
incredibly difficult time over the past
uh three months
and you have to help 82 companies or a
little
less go through this journey of dealing
with cover 19 and you actually have to
do it also with a newborn
congratulations
beautiful maya what is that like what is
your role
as the vc partner in helping these
portfolio companies push through this so
first of all it's not
uh it's an individual sport right i mean
it's it's myself my partners but also
the other
great investors that backed our
companies um
and uh you know i think for us it's
giving a sanity check to the founders
and also helping spread information what
others are doing so
for example in the very beginning it's
really encouraging them to take a close
look
at their runway and not be shy in making
decisions some of them tough um about
their workforce
because the longer you procrastinate and
say
you know we'll have to wait the more
painful it becomes afterwards so it's
having
those um you know uh uh
eyes wide open conversation did you have
to put
did you have a situation where you had
where you pushed
a founder to make that difficult
decision and you feel like if you
weren't in the picture they might not
have been able to make it
yeah you know i don't i wouldn't say
push them i think
uh maybe push them to think uh about
other alternatives
and sometimes it's not just about us um
it's about connecting them maybe to
other founders
we also bought people that um were you
know back in 2008
uh saw the previous recession and had to
overcome
that so it's not just about what i know
what i think it's about
sort of being sort of their advisor and
shepherding shepherding them through the
process
and do you and i mean do you approach
this optimistically
pessimistically or realistically well
how what's your position at the dinner
table
with with your founding team you know
there's no pessimist in the world
there's only optimist and realists right
um now uh i think
i think you know as a beast as a venture
capitalist as a founder
you have to have some heavy dose of
optimism right
it makes no sense to start a company and
try to battle these
incredible giants or overcome of the
obstacles so you need to have
uh this level of optimism um so we do go
into it but at the same
time you know you need to plan for the
worst and the worst
is you need to have 18 24 months of
runway
for example and not just say you know
this will be a v-shaped recovery and in
three months everything will be fine
you know what let's all hope so that's
the case but let's plan for it
not being whatsoever that amazing
yo what what excites you after nine
years
uh thousands of of potential deals 82
investments
well what gets you up in the morning
what are you really really excited about
um lots of things um
you know i can't i'm not i don't think
i'm one of those investors that says you
know this domain or that domain
i think for me it really comes to the
people that we meet
at a coffee shop on the corner of
rothschild avenue and something in tel
aviv
when they only have the gleam in the
eyes and they just started
and it's about trying to see if if sort
of we can help guide them
through coming to the us and and growing
their business to become what
we think it can become so i think it's
that optimism that belief those early
days
the process the ups the downs um
i think the journey itself is what
excites me uh
certainly new technologies impact on the
world i i
i'm completely on board but it's but
it's i think being part of the journey
of
you know one person against the world
calling quote that
i like uh like being part of and and
how would you describe your your
engagement with them some vcs are very
hands off
take my money and leave sort of dumb
money some of them are you know let's
you know
let's come sit in our offices giving a
small hand but
but how how do you approach this
relationship of yours with your
portfolio companies at such an early
stage
yeah look i think um
each investor wants to contribute
i think each investor plays a different
role so at the very beginning we are
almost always the first and only money
in the company
so it's about typically guiding them in
the right direction
avoiding making big mistakes helping
them make some decisions at the early on
helping them to find additional
investors that can invest
and over time that evolves because now
they have different advisors
that uh bring something else to the
table so for us we have to ask ourselves
okay
how do we change our position and advice
to complement some of the other
uh people that is supporting the ceo and
the founders
so even our role changes over time
not only but at the end also i mean i i
get i got to be in the up west offices
quite a few times at this point it's
practically my second home outside of
the stanford dorms
you walk in and you see i don't know
like five six different companies
sitting in their tables talking to each
other all friends
everybody's so nice it's kind of like a
hub it reminds me of
of the of the google campus that was
back in a lecture building
you know a few years ago where you walk
in and there's this electricity and fire
and so it and it doesn't look like it's
a vc office it looks like it's
a workspace where you're not just giving
money to
the portfolio companies are actually
giving mentorship and friendship
and the community for them to work
together in the heart of silicon valley
which is not
away from tel aviv where they get to be
with other israelis right in the same
room
yeah two things about it you completely
right first of all the community
critical word for us it's about founders
going shared experiences
that actually are pretty unique to them
when you think about it
you move to the us you come with your
significant other with kids
many of them you know that's not easy
whatsoever
so you shared experiences both of
companies at the same stage but also
those that came
one two five years ahead of you so we
make sure
to bring all that to the table but the
second thing is
we absolutely make sure that folks are
not sort of sitting within themselves
it's about pushing them out
immersing in the ecosystem uh just
because the culture the business here
can be um at first challenging and
not that straightforward to understand
um i'm still figuring it out right so
uh almost a couple of decades onwards so
uh
it's about definitely being out there
it's very easy to get into your shell
and be with young folks but you
absolutely have to be out there to
succeed
definitely are things changing in the in
the vc world
what's happening is our things have been
the same over the past few decades
where do you see uh things going forward
not just with upwards but general
venture capital uh relationship with
entrepreneurs
let's see in the next decade yeah i
don't know if i'm smart enough to
sort of see the next decade but you know
there's definitely the last couple
10 years plus have been some definitely
big changes um
i think the definition of venture
capital has changed
what vc's bring to the table many firms
have taken that
to add lots of of experiences and value
ads in various ways
so it's not just the partners in the
fund um
funds of all sizes right in the past
seed funds what is a seed fund
anything below 50 100 didn't make any
sense now you have
super angels turning seed funds that
happened a decade ago
or so began at least really fantastic
funds there
obviously the soft bank phenomena and
funds not raising 300 but 3 billion
and even 100 billion as we saw so
things have changed a lot but the
corvette hasn't evolved
which is trying to get conviction
um about a team hoping that that they
get conviction about you
because you're about to spend seven to
ten years
uh working together so you want this
mutual respect exactly hopefully
huge respect mutual ability to work
together so finding though
uh those partnerships with the founders
is
uh not easy it actually shouldn't be
easy
you know it's a big decision for both
sides um
that hasn't changed right you know i i
now i'm talking as the young
entrepreneur
and i get to surround myself with
incredible other young entrepreneurs
much smarter than me and both from 8200
and stanford
i'm just amazed by some of the things
that some of them are doing and
and it's very confusing and there's a
lot of options
a lot of places to go um how
how does a young entrepreneur balance
their their journey
and you know on one hand there is this
pride and i'm gonna go raise money and
i'm gonna go to
i'm gonna finish my combinator and raise
the biggest seed round i can raise
the other hand you have the more
conservative approach of i'm actually i
i'm not sure that i need money i can
maybe bootstrap this or maybe i'm
looking for specific strategic investors
so how does young entrepreneur like
myself navigate through all these
options
and and what's the most important thing
to keep in mind as i'm building my team
as i'm building my strategy to
eventually make a big impact
great question so first of all there's
no one way right there's no one way
no no one way that treats everything i
think if for young founders i think it's
about
surrounding yourself with the right type
of advisors or friends
and experiences that you gather along
the way and see what works for you
sometimes you know it's about getting
you choose you
you're knowledgeable about business that
you're super passionate about
and you can make it into a bootstrap and
you can work on it before fundraising if
at all
um sometimes it's you know you have
maybe some technical skills or unique
uh team that you put together that you
really have to raise a meaningful seed
to show something um uh meaningful at
the early stage so there's no one answer
but i think i would encourage everyone
to uh especially in stanford you know
make those internships count during the
during the years during the summer make
them as diverse as humanly possible
reach out to people have coffee shots
coffee chats
i actually um uh i think as as
you know my journey uh took me here um
i spoke to many dozens of venture
capitalists
before even knowing what that is and
deciding to jump into the deep end and
this is
10 years post mba so i took full
advantage of my personal network my
business professional networks
to just talk to people and see what they
say and what they've learned and their
experiences
and then figure out the right path for
me and the right path for me
was not to join a big vc
but we had the opportunity to start our
own truly and me and
bootstrap with if you can believe it at
the very beginning so
um that was the answer for us does that
mean that's the answer for
everyone uh in our profession no sure
yeah no
it seems like there is a growing trend
where relationships are not so much
about
uh the long term but it's more about
what can you offer me today so that and
i can offer you something tomorrow
and which is kind of disheartening and
you see it with the competitive nature i
think
sometimes at a place like stanford
there's a lot of others who are very
interested in forming these personal
relationships i value them a lot
and and that's why i i love doing what
we're doing here and getting to know you
over these years and hopefully
one day i can be in front of you and
i'll be one of the thousands of decks
that you receive in your mailbox
hopefully sooner rather than later
and gil last thoughts about about where
where are you headed with this are you
do you see yourself continuing with
upwards growing it into
into a massive vc do you see yourself
navigating
potentially to other areas what's up
with you
so as much as i can help it and control
things
this is the last job i want to be doing
right i've no
doubt to do anything else it's our
startup
right this is our startup this is the
start of course
we boost up it we raise money from
people um we're trying to grow to a
certain extent
um but that's what sort of
we do right you can ask email i asked
you
i thought i thought we were we might
talk about uh being a vc versus
starting a startup but you're actually
starting a startup while doing a video
yeah um so this i an absolutely treated
that way
um and going forward we do want to scale
a little bit but ultimately what will
guide us
is we want to invest in very early stage
startups funded by israelis wherever
they are and help them break into the
earth's market if we raise
too much money it doesn't make change
make sense to
write a precedent check we now have to
be a serious a fund
which a is less fun for me and b there's
so many better investors so many better
investors than us to do it so we want to
specialize
in being that first check and so we have
to right-size the funds
so we can't raise too much right
gil three words that best describe you
and now i'm ready for the cheating
so the cheating is um i'm a big fan of
hyphens
all right i i would be hyphenating a
little bit here
um so on on on sort of the
the business uh side i aspire to be
a a trusted advisor so that's a
hyphenated
uh word um you know that's that's what i
would like to
to continue to be and aspire to be and
hopefully
i can continue perfecting that um on a
personal level
uh as you see me sitting in a pink room
here i
i will take on the description of uh
simple of
like a father i i'm i'm still figuring
it out and would like to figure it out
for a long time so
that would be my second word and i
didn't cheat here that's that's a
non-hyphenated
i love it it looks kind of white but now
i'll make it clear this is a pink room
gillis sitting in his in his in your
daughter's room right
yeah light pink room exactly um
uh and then the third i i didn't know to
say so i'll just go with
um and this is absolutely hyphenated um
from sabah i'm a proud
uh a dual citizen of israel the us
um but where i grew up my roots
uh it's from for salva and what that
means to me is
um community family
and that is where i'm from and where i
started and
you know uh frankly all my family
cousins aunts about 40 close members of
my family all live
five minutes from one another walking
distance and i'm beyond who isn't
so i'm like the black sheep of the
family um but uh
uh yeah that's that's the third uh
word i love it that i used to describe
myself
best of luck it sounds amazing and look
for my email with the deck in
one or two years thank you so much
thank you for having me
you